one of the most important psychedelic
experiences of my life was a dmt
experience also terence was there
ralph metzner andy weil a few others
and we were sitting around
ed eslin smoking dmt and under the
influence of dmt
which now this was the first time i've
ever smoked emt
i had this super rapid fraction of a
second like uh dissolving of everything
that i
well first off i saw a horizontal line
then i saw a vertical line
then it turned into a color red then it
was red then it turned into cubes
then it turned into like an m.c escher
kind of like i don't know
you know didn't make logical sense and
then i was gone
and then it was just this period of
five ten minutes of just feeling part of
this enormous
wave of billions of years of evolution
how
i had the sense that in my innermost
sense of who
i am uniquely individually this inner
voice that's talking to me that i didn't
develop english that that it's like a
gift to me from
millions of people that so that even in
my most innermost
sense it's not just me it's it's the
product of everything that came before
me i'm part of this bigger
system and then i just thought wow just
how many billions of years does it take
to reach this point self-awareness and
all this and it was glorious beautiful
and then i had this thought
um and this is where this kind of
intellectual honesty i guess you could
say i just thought well if i'm part of
everything and everything's part of me
then it's not just the good parts that
hitler's part of me too
yeah and that was just this shock like a
stone
sunk you know and i just was very moody
for the whole
next day but it was that acknowledgement
that each of us
carries these potentials and what we
activate is what matters but
what our potential are is the whole full
range of things
i don't know if you can comment about
the dmt trip itself and what it's like
starting from the very basic geometric
shapes and then launching
yourself into the context of the
enormity of space and time in the human
history
is there anything else to be said about
that kind of um
visually or physically
or emotionally about that journey what
it's
what it's like that brief journey that
reveals so much
well i was with a group of people the
way we were doing it
was um you know each of us would smoke
dmt
have 10 15 minutes experience while we
closed our eyes and you know everybody
else was just
chatting and then the person who did the
dmt would come back and tell their story
what happened and and then we'd think
about it for a bit and then pass the
pipe to the next person and so this was
like a whole
evening you know and so even the
starting to interrupt even the
conversations themselves then is part of
the experience
exactly yes yes because it's also what
you bring back
right i mean i think that's particularly
for therapy you know it's not so much
about what the
experience is but it's what you bring
back
and what do you integrate and then also
um
how do you learn how to do these things
on your own without the drugs
there is this way because we're saying
it's it's sort of a core human
experience the drug is the mediator but
can we
do this on our own and once you've seen
it and felt it then you have a little
bit better sense to
recreate it on your own although you
know i've had dreams where i've been
doing lsd
and tripping and it was just incredible
it was
i was tripping in my dreams but i had
not taken lsd
so there's this way in which we do that
so i
i would say that from the dmt experience
the sense of safety that's what i was
trying to get at with this
group of us and this group of friends
trying to do this common exploration
that
if you have this sense of safety you're
incredibly
vulnerable because you are
giving up your awareness really of
what's happening around you
i think there's what we're finding
is that in our psychedelic research
for ptsd um
and what we see with the vaccines that
that even african americans are
reluctant to volunteer for vaccines
because they
haven't had that sense of safety from
the medical establishment
they don't volunteer for psychedelic
therapy even as much
so the overlay has to be this sense of
safety as you
become vulnerable and looking inside
you're you're not
um i i was just actually told about how
there's a lot of work being done inside
prisons to teach mindfulness
and you know so one of the um
charlene who's my assistant is trying to
do work on um
helping people in prison with trauma
potentially one day with mdma or
meditation or mindfulness but
one of the exercises was you know
teaching people to okay
here's how you deal with stress you know
just close your eyes and deep breath and
what charlene was saying is people don't
close their eyes in prison
you know you don't feel safe to do that
so um
all that is just to say is that um
the context is the most important factor
so while i'll talk about
the dmt experience the context was this
supportive sense of safety that i could
be completely vulnerable and
out of any kind of control women i think
you know
often are less safe in this way than men
because of all the sexual assaults
but what it can do by taking the ego
orientation
offline to some extent it opens you up
to much more
and and to make a bigger point of that
um we could say that it's very similar
to the copernican revolution
and you know people thought that the
earth was the center of the universe
and you know the the inquisition
murdered people that
questioned that uh father bruno burned
at the stake actually one of the things
he said
i think that's worth all these years
later um
saying is that when the inquisition um
sentenced him to burn at the stake for
espousing this idea that the earth was
not really the center of the universe he
said to the inquisition
he said your fear in sentencing me is
greater than my
fear in being sentenced
that their worldview was so rigid that
they had to wipe out anybody that would
question
it and and so
this idea of psychedelics displacing our
ego is the center of the universe
and to realize that we are just rotating
about something much bigger than our
individual life
you know our ego is is designed almost
to protect this body
while we're alive and you can understand
all the good reasons why that is
but it also disconnects us from this
bigger reality
and so the psychedelics dmt by knocking
this
sort of ego orientation or the default
mode network
offline you open up to the the bigger
sweeps of history so in that place of
safety and vulnerability
in that fascinating group of people when
their ego was dissolved in this way did
they have similar experiences
is there different places that their
minds went yeah
so you know once i had this kind of
shattering experience that hitler's part
of me
yes you know no one else in the group
had that probably
a lot of them have maybe had that before
or they they realize that they're not
just
you know the good the white hat good
people and that they're all good and
they're you know we've got to fight
against the bad people
you know so no people will go in
different places and not only that
if you do it again you'll go into a
different place than you went to the
first time
unless you have not resolved the issues
so i had a sequence of lsd
trips that were very difficult but it
was like coming to the same
sort of conundrum the same challenge
that i was unable to overcome this idea
of letting go and really fully
dissolving
um letting the ego fully go and and i
would have this sequence of trips over a
couple months where i would reach this
point where i was too scared to move
forward and i would just be holding on
so there are there are repeated themes
sometimes
what stan groff has said which i find
very beautiful is that the
full expression of an emotion is the
funeral pyre of that emotion
and what that means is if you can fully
let in
something then the essence of uh of life
has changed
is that it moves on that everything's in
motion
and if you can fully experience it even
if it's a sense that you're going to be
trapped in eternity
in this hellish state if you surrender
to that that's the way out
you know this full experience of
something is this
funeral power of that emotion and so
that
runs against a lot of what modern
psychiatry is doing too which is to
suppress symptoms
and to and to instead of supporting
people to kind of explore these
insecurities so that then they can
contain them
and then they can move on so yeah
resistance
is not a way to make progress right
right although in one of the reasons why
we do the supplemental dose during the
mdma or why
there's advantages in a 10 hour lsd
experience
is that you have a lot of opportunities
to come up against
this resistance it may be too difficult
to deal with and then you kind of push
it aside and then a couple hours later
you come back to it or you come back to
it press news every once in a while
if you're not ready it's hard to do that
i think the with mdma
you can negotiate that's i think a part
of
its safety in a sense you can have this
like oh i should be talking about
this but i where i'm feeling this but
it's too much for me now
you can push it away but with the
classic psychedelics
this kind of membrane between the
conscious and the unconscious
that once you take the drug and it
weakens this membrane and things are
coming up
it's very difficult to negotiate with it
the the
the key to successful
classic psychedelic trips is surrender
you